let's do another example where we're
projecting something and it lands at a
different level it will also figure out
some other interesting things we'll
figure out what the actual velocity
vector is when it's landing so both its
magnitude and its direction so let's do
a situation so let's say we're launching
something from ground level and we're
going to launch it at a pretty steep
angle over here so let's say we launch
it with an angle let's say we launch it
with an angle of let me just let's say
it's 80 degrees we launch it with an
eight at an 80 degree angle at let me we
launch it at an 80 degree angle 80
degree angle and it is going to be going
at 30 meters per second 30 meters per
second so that's the length of this
vector that's the magnitude of that
vector and let's say we want to make it
land on this landing and this is landing
right over here this landing right over
here has a height this landing over here
has a height of 10 meters this height
over here is 10 meters so what I want to
do first of all is I want to figure out
how far along the landing how far along
the landing do I actually land how far
along the landing so and maybe I'll add
some other information right here so say
from this launching point to the
beginning of the landing let's say that
this right over here is 2 meters 2
meters so we just want to know how far
along the landing do we land so like we
did before we want if we want to break
this vector into its horizontal and
vertical components its horizontal and
vertical components and I'm going to go
a little bit faster in this video
because hopefully we're getting the
knack for this type of thing so our
velocity our velocity in the vertical or
our vertical component of our velocity
is going to be equal to the magnitude of
our total velocity 30 meters per second
times and it's going to be the sine of
80 degrees because sine is opposite over
hypotenuse times the sine of 80 degrees
and our and we'll just get it out of the
way right now the horizontal component
of our velocity is going to be 30 meters
per second and I'm not writing the
unit's here just to save some space
times the cosine of a
once again cosine is adjacent adjacent
adjacent over hypotenuse and if you feel
like I'm skipping steps in the last few
videos I go into this into much more
detail so what how much time do we spend
in the air how much time do we spend in
the air so once again in the last few
videos we saw that we can look at our we
can look at displacement if we want to
figure out time in the air we know that
displacement is equal to the initial
velocity initial velocity times time
plus acceleration let me write times
change in time since that's more
technically that's technically more
correct plus acceleration times change
in time squared over over 2 now in our
situation we know what our initial
velocity is we're talking about the
vertical direction right over here so
our initial velocity is going to be this
we're trying to figure out how time in
the air and the vertical component
determines that because at some point
when it hits back to the ground it's not
going to be traveling anymore so that's
what's determining its time in the air
so we know that we know the acceleration
remember our convention when we're
dealing with the vertical dimension is
up is positive down is negative so this
is negative 9.8 meters per second
squared and then we can and then what is
the total displacement that we're going
to have well we're starting at ground
level and we're just talking about the
vertical remember that so our total
displacement is going to be 10 meters so
this value right here is going to be 10
meters so it simplifies to 10 meters I
won't write the unit's here as equals 10
is equal to what's 30 sine of 80 degrees
so we have 30 times the sine of 80
degrees gives us 29.54 29.54 so this is
29.54
times our change in time times our
change in time and so this is negative
9.8 divided by 2 so it's negative I'll
do that same green color for point
that's not the same green color negative
4.9 m/s squared I'm not
the units here times delta T squared
times delta T squared and then we could
subtract 10 from both sides and write
this in a traditional quadratic equation
form so we get negative and I'm going to
flip the sides to negative 4.9 times
delta T squared and then we have plus
29.54
times Delta t minus 10 minus 10 is equal
to zero and then we can use the
quadratic formula to find the roots of
this so the Delta T's that satisfy this
quadratic equation are going to be
negative B so negative 29.54 plus or
minus the square root of 29.54 squared b
squared minus 4 minus 4 times a which is
negative 4.9 so the negative times a
negative is a positive so it's plus 4
times positive 4.9 times I shouldn't
have I shouldn't have jumped so fast to
get rid of the negative so it's going to
be minus 4 times a which is negative 4.9
times C which is negative 10 so just a
times C negative 4.9 times negative 10
so let me just write negative 4.9 times
negative 10 these two guys their signs
are going to cancel out all of that all
of that over all of that over 2a all of
that over negative 4.9 times 2 so
negative 9.8 and like we saw in the last
video we want a positive value for this
a negative time is nonsensical that's
kind of going into the past so we want a
positive value and since we have a
negative in the denominator we want to
have a negative value up here and if we
already have a negative value here if we
subtract from that negative value we're
definitely to have a negative value up
here and then you divide by a negative
value we'll get a positive value so we
can really focus on the subtracting the
radical and you could try it out if you
try the positive version you're going to
get a negative value for this entire
thing do that on you could try that out
after this video just to verify that
you'll get a nonsensical answer so let's
use the negative right over here so we
have negative 29.54
- the square root of the square root of
29.54 squared and then we have minus
four minus four times negative four
point nine times negative ten these two
when you take the product is positive 49
so x times 49 and I should add a I
should add a parenthesis over there so
let me insert a parenthesis you can
insert parenthesis okay
so times 49 so this right here will give
me the numerator if I evaluate this it
got me a negative value and then I
divide that by negative 9.8 so divided
by negative 9.8 gives me five point six
seven five point six seven seconds this
is equal to five point six seven seconds
and you could keep the units in there
and make sure that all of the
dimensional analysis works and I think
you'll find that it does so our total
our total vertical or the total time in
the air is five point six the total time
in the air is five point six seven
seconds now what I want to do the whole
point of this is to figure out is to
figure out how far along this landing we
land
well our horizontal component of our
velocity is right over here we know that
we know that our displacement in the
horizontal direction our displacement in
the horizontal direction will be our
velocity in the horizontal direction and
it's a constant velocity so it's the
same thing as our average velocity in
the horizontal Direction times the
change in time well the change in time
is so I'll just write it out times our
change in time so this is going to be
equal to 30 cosine of 80 degrees 30
cosine of eighty degrees times five
point six seven seconds times five point
six seven seconds and this I won't write
the unit's this is meters per second
times seconds it'll give us an answer in
meters so once again we have this is our
time this is a five point six seven
times 30 cosine of eighty degrees gives
us 29 point five three meters so
our total horizontal travelling
displacement I guess we could say is 29
I already forgot the number twenty nine
point five three meters twenty nine
point five three meters and I alright
this is a vector that is our horizontal
displacement it's equal to twenty nine
point five three meters now we've done a
lot of deconstructing vectors what I
thought would be interesting in this
video is to construct a vector so we
know our horizontal displacement we also
know our vertical displacement it's
positive ten meters so what's our total
displacement let me write this down so
we have a horizontal displacement we
have a horizontal displacement of twenty
nine point five three meters and we have
a vertical displacement of +10 meters we
have a vertical displacement of positive
ten meters and so what is our total
displacement what is our total
displacement going to be well we could
use the Pythagorean theorem now here the
square of the magnitude of our total
displacement is going to be equal to the
sum of these two squares or another way
this is just the Pythagorean theorem so
we could have if we call this length
over here C or let me just write it this
is a magnitude of our displacement right
over here the magnitude of our total
displacement squared is going to be
equal to ten squared plus twenty nine
point five three squared so it's going
to be ten squared plus twenty nine point
five three squared I'm going to do that
same color plus twenty nine point five
three squared if we want to solve for
this we just take this the square root
of both sides so I'll just do that in
place so if we just take the square root
of both sides we will get the magnitude
of our total displacement and I can get
the calculator out once again to do that
so the magnitude of our total
displacement is the square root of 10
squared is just 100 plus 29 I can even
use well I could use all of this
information so I don't even lose some
precision I could say second answer that
literally means the previous answer
which is that twenty nine point five
three squared gives us a total
displacement of 31 point one eight
meters
so this is equal to 31 point 1 8 meters
and of course it's a vector so we did
we've only given you the magnitude we
also need the direction so one way to
specify a direction is to give you the
angle with the horizontal and let's call
that angle theta and once again we can
use our trig our trig functions over
here we could use pretty much any of the
trig functions but we know the opposite
side is 10 we know the we know the
hypotenuse here is 30 1.18 so why not
use sine sine is opposite over
hypotenuse so we know that the sine of
theta is going to be equal to 10 over 30
1.18 10 over 30 1.18 or if you want to
solve for theta you take the arc sine of
both sides or the inverse sine of both
sides you get theta is equal to the
inverse sine or I could write arc sine
over here of of 10 of 10 over 30 1.8 10
over 30 1.18 I should say so let's once
again get the calculator out to figure
out that value so I'm going to take the
inverse sine once against this is the
same thing as the arc sine this is says
give me the angle that when I take its
sine I get this value right over here so
the inverse sine of 10 divided by our
previous answer 30 1.18 I'll just say
our previous answer is equal to so this
says give me the angle whose sine is 10
over 30 1.18 so I have eighteen point
seven degrees or 18 point seven one
degrees so this is equal to eighteen
point seven one degrees eighteen point
seven one degrees above the horizontal
so here we've constructed a vector we
took its vertical component and its
horizontal component and we were able to
figure out the total vector so this this
projectile in this situation is going
it's total displacement so just to make
it clear its path will look something
like this its path will look something
like this its path is going to look
something like this and we've just
calculated its total displacement its
total displacement is 30
one point one eight meters eighteen
point seven one degrees above the
horizontal now the other thing I
realized that when I started this
problem I asked you I think I was asking
you how far along the platform and we
figured out its total horizontal
displacement so if you want to know how
far along the platform the platform
starts two meters to the right so it's
really twenty seven point five three
meters along the platform is where it
lands